a Brit and an American swap countries to
try each other's dominoes this is food
world
we're going to start by comparing a menu
item you can find in both the US and the
UK to see if there are subtle
differences this is a U.S large cheese
pizza this is their largest size
feels like it's a little bit bigger than
our medium in terms of visual
Impressions it looks pretty similar to a
cheese pizza that I find in the UK this
is the large not the extra large and
honestly it looks pretty much like the
size that I would expect from a large
pizza in the UK otherwise it looks
pretty similar in terms of the crust
obviously a lot of cheese on that you
get these little like spots where the
cheese kind of caramelizes on top yeah
pretty much like what I'm used to in the
UK
uh seems pretty close actually I can
definitely tell this is uh mozzarella
cheese in that whatever weird pizza
cheese we have in the U.S so
um yeah this is like it's like a cleaner
taste I like this this is good give it a
try I don't know how to Domino's in ages
it's also looking like there's a pretty
high cheese to Sauce ratio on that I
feel like if you look at the kind of
cross section
it's a lot of cheese and not a ton of
sauce
that's really not that bad I have had
some New York slices while I've been
here and it's kind of comparable to one
of those I feel like I might offend some
New Yorkers by saying that
there's a lot of like tuts happening
around the room right now what I mean by
that is uh I think like in terms of the
way that the cheese and the sauce Blends
together there's like less of a
distinction between the cheese and the
sauce it kind of just all forms one mass
and in that regard I feel like it's
similar to a New York size there are
some differences though the crust on
this is like way less crispy than I have
come to associate with the New York
slice there's also maybe not quite as
much flavor as some of the slices that
I've tried
ah here's all the UK Domino's menu items
I can't get in the U.S and here are all
the Domino's menu items from the US
which you can't find in the UK
you guys have exclusive dough options
I don't know about this one guys
the double decadence you got like a
double layer
uh crust with like a garlicky cheese in
the in the middle there here in the UK a
garlic an herb stuffed crust pizza this
this one also looks terrible then a
crispy crust this has to be half price
or you're getting ripped off what is
this crust
what's Italian style yeah it's like not
instant but it's still thinner
so man you guys really get specific with
the thickness of your crust I really
want to dial that in huh yeah this I'd
be like in America this would be the
thin crust this would be like yeah I got
that I got the thin one right and then
this would be like
people just rioting Domino's in the US
has crust options which we don't have in
the UK we'll start with this one which
is the pan crust I mean it looks pretty
good it is obviously much thicker than
the standard hand tossed slice was you
do get that kind of like pan crust
bottom there as well
I like that you get more source and more
distinct areas of sauce on this than the
standard size I think often for me like
the sauce is kind of the star of the
show especially when it's a fast food
pizza
and the cheese generally doesn't have
that much flavor to it I will say I was
expecting it to be crispier on the
bottom when you see the kind of like
the cook marks on the bottom I was
expecting that to be a nice solid crust
but it is kind of squidgy not too bad
let me try a little bit of crust
slightly crisper on the edge next up
we've got the Brooklyn crust now I've
already made comparisons to New York
slices which have drawn some criticism
from the room but this is supposed to
mimic a New York slice as I now know
from a New York slice generally you're
talking low moisture mozzarella the
sauce
and that kind of mixture of like crispy
but a little bit floppy on the crust
which kind of this is doing to be honest
so it sort of looks like a New York
slice
but does it taste like one
no no it doesn't I'm sorry to uh the
great state of New York for what
Domino's has done to your pizzas
and then finally Domino's in the US does
a gluten-free base I don't know what
they've done to this gluten-free base
they've cut it so weirdly can you see
the cross sections on this I think maybe
they were trying to do it into squares
but have just completely messed up the
angle so now you get these like weird
kind of
diamond shaped slice in the middle
some like tiny triangle ones on the
sides I don't know
oh man right oh man
no
that's bad well they've done that
yeah that's uh that's a Miss I feel like
if I were gluten-free
I think I might just skip Domino's all
right
let's go through these pizzas veggie
volcano veggies and jalapenos making it
volcanoe
let's go spice it up
nope
a little good off to a good start the
next veggie the veg Aroma this one has
like a lot of seasoning on it no so here
we got the this is spicy our hot and
spicy not that spicy I mean I'm seeing
the jalapenos in here that other one the
volcano one was spicier and Dory hot
okay I am excited for this I'm for real
there's no tandoori chicken pizza in the
U.S yeah that's good that's good let's
go compared to other tandoori chicken
this probably is like uh not even
remotely good but on the pizza yeah
that's a cool that's like a
that's a nice flavor profile combination
they got there yeah good on it for that
one good job so here are all the
Domino's pre-made pizzas I can get in
the U.S which you can't find in the UK
on like a sort of visual level these
look a lot busier than I would expect a
pizza in the UK to look like these
things are topped so we'll start with
this one which is the Philly cheese
steak Pizza
Philly cheesesteak an iconic American
food I've never really had a proper
American Philly cheesesteak before this
is my introduction to them which I'm
sure the people of Philly will be
thrilled to hear
it's very creamy and I think the texture
of the American cheese is a bit like
claggy in the mouth I don't love the
peppers I feel like the peppers are kind
of overpowering it a lot they've been
really generous with the peppers and not
super generous with the steak I feel
like if you flipped the ratio of those
toppings this would be okay next up we
have the Wisconsin six cheese okay so
this is a very cheesy pizza I'm told
Wisconsin is known for its Dairy and I
suppose it's cheese production
they've actually been quite generous
with the sauce under the cheese which I
like because you need it to like cut
through all of that Dairy okay the r
veggie Supreme
oh no
corn and pizza no
[Music]
oh God I can really taste the corn meat
delicious guys come on oh no
I'm realizing something I do not have a
taste for UK sausage
whatever we've been getting for these
shoots I think because your guys's pork
and beef but like the way you're spicing
it there's something about it I get it
why you guys would like and you grew up
eating it
we'll get well good guy hairy sausage
when it comes to the US and you'll see
what I mean maybe that maybe it's a
different type of sausage we just name
it something different but this
sausage you guys have is weird oh yeah
Texas I see the barbecue besides that
why else is this Texas I see chicken I
see a few sparse slices of bacon or ham
yeah all this stuff is in Texas
this does not represent the state of
Texas in any way next up we have the
Extravaganza this one I think is
probably the most chaotic in terms of
toppings what have we even got on here
I'm seeing ham
pepperoni sausage mushrooms peppers
onions and black olives and I feel like
I still might have missed some things I
feel like I'm being overloaded right now
you think you've kind of like identified
what the flavor of it is and then you
bite down on something else and then
suddenly you're tasting something
completely different next up is the
Memphis Barbecue pizza now this one has
the barbecue sauce base I believe it
does have provolone as well as
mozzarella on it which might explain
some of the extra cheesiness and then
you have some onions and the grilled
chicken
cool I know it is a sweet barbecue sauce
technically and they are not kidding
when they say that because this is a
very very sweet
very very sweet barbecue sauce and I
think that does kind of overpower
anything else that's going on TC Mighty
meat
okay oh yeah this guy again
this has to be half price are you
getting ripped off
this thing it's a cheeseburger pizza the
cheeseburger US Pizza I did really like
what is burger sauce is on here
yeah
I like this
good
I'm eating them on the pickles
ladies and gentlemen the absolute banger
[Music]
why is it what is absolutely banging
about this okay one two
three
just bring it all to the front guys
one bite
I don't know if it's really Banger next
up we have the Deluxe pizza this looks
like a slightly less chaotic version of
the Extravaganza there's still like a
lot of toppings on here but not quite so
many it's not like pile high like the
Extravaganza was so if it tastes any
less chaotic than it's uh slightly more
packed out cousin
what I'm realizing is I don't really
like peppers on Pizza I feel like it's
quite a strong flavor and when you get a
fast food pizza specifically where most
of the toppings and the cheese and the
sauce don't really offer that much in
terms of taste I feel like you have to
be quite careful with your flavor
balance and peppers are kind of throwing
that off for me next up we have the Cali
chicken bacon ranch so this one has
chicken bacon diced tomatoes I believe
our old friend provolone is back again
and of course there is ranch on this
pizza
you can see the ranch so it's basically
the ranch in lieu of tomato sauce on the
bottom I still think I just prefer
tomato sauce on a pizza I don't think I
will be swapping out my pizza sauce for
ranch anytime soon at home good Lord
guys no I'm gonna try meatball
could someone intelligent in the
comments explain different U.S sausage
and meatballs and UK sausage and
meatballs it's just it's notably
different
oh
the meteor
too much too much veggies
Sizzler
or spicy
Switzerland
now this is weird to say this but is it
unfair or cheating to the market
something is being really sizzling and
spicy if all you're doing is dumping
jalapenos on it right I don't think they
did anything to like it's not like a
spicy sauce didn't add like any other
spices to it from what I can tell it's
just loaded with jalapenos which is like
well right
but
a little more effort than that guys New
Yorker what
I feel like I've seen this before
no
in the past five minutes
[Music]
next up is the spinach feta Pizza
I think I'll stick to my spanakopita
instead of uh my spinach from feta Pizza
this is the buffalo chicken pizza we
have chicken onions and quite a lot of
buffalo sauce
that's barely even a pizza I don't know
if you can call that pizza oh no it's
the breakfast bricky or the brekkie oh
look what I did to the fox
mushrooms the sausage ham tomatoes and
HP Sauce
I think I think people would get this as
a novelty and then realize that the
joke's on them when it shows up here we
go with the vegan margarita
they were generous with that uh with the
herbs whatever the extra herbs they're
generous of that which is code for this
has no taste
tuna Supreme
oh God it looks like cat food tuna and
pizza is horrifying I see no Venn
diagram of enjoyment on those two
flavors two completely separate circles
I feel like every alley cat's gonna try
and like break in here through the
window oh
oh you people are insane this whole
island
Maniacs oh give me I gotta eat anything
else the taste in my mouth what's the
next one
I don't even care what it is
uh Chicken Feast
oh it's the corn
that's good anything else
yeah no if you want to sell more Chicken
Feast Pieces Just give away free tuna
pizzas
and then people are like I just taste my
mouth it's like you know it'll cost you
you got it right here yeah you're gonna
move a lot of chicken feasts
next up we have the Pacific Veggie Pizza
not sure what makes this Pacific all
right these veggies exclusive to the
Pacific as far as I can tell it's
mushroom onion Olive tomato
spinach
it's okay having eaten several pizzas in
a row that contain meat in some form or
other I was quite looking forward to a
veggie one hoping it would be a bit
lighter but it kind of isn't and then
finally the last specialty pizza on the
Domino's us menu is the mitsa having
just gone from a veggie only pizza now
I'm going to a meat only Pizza this one
has bacon ham pepperoni and sausage
something about American meat
but I think it's just generally a lot
saltier than what we used to in the UK
as I was chewing that I could just feel
my mouth like drying out
I think generally my takeaway from this
section is you guys need to just calm
down slightly because this is too much
all right
we got here reduced fat cheese which
I've been told is on the UK or the UK
only Pizza no you
okay I don't know what to show you I
mean it looks like cheese and then vegan
cheese this is gonna be but it comes
with its own
garlic and herb dip vegan let's see what
the vegans got going on
it tastes sour sauce options you only
get in the UK starting over here just a
straight barbecue sauce we have honey
barbecue they have regular barbecue and
then over here this monstrosity has
sun-dried tomatoes and garlic sauce they
have four exclusive meat toppings here
in the UK hot dog slices unreal chorizo
sausage sounds nice pork meatballs
tandoori chicken yeah that sounds real
good they also have two meatless meat
options vegan soya strips and vegan soya
and wheat pepperoni I think we saw that
earlier they have seven non-meat topping
options sweet corn dominoes herbs burger
sauce gherkins Heinz Ketchup HP Sauce
and garlic spread here it is the UK only
it looks like an alien Community open to
pizza place
and they were like here's that pizza you
like like this is all things humans like
and I'm together a light like this like
the completely fundamental
misunderstanding of how Food Works
whoa
that was really bad
now beyond the pre-made specialty pizzas
they have some individual toppings and
customization options in the US which we
can't find in the UK so Joe has kindly
taken a bunch of the exclusive us
toppings and added them to one pizza to
create a us only
I don't even know what he's put on here
the crust looks weird I think he's gone
thin crust banana peppers spinach is
back on there
there's this looks like a meat of some
kind but I can't tell you which one
is that like beef the steak from the
Philly cheese steak the base sauce has
been swapped out for ranch of course and
the extra of that and light cheese I
mean
this thing looks like a bit of a
disaster
how thin that is
what have you done ma'am oh that's bad
damage in UK also has its own sides that
I haven't had ever so why not try them
now starting over here
potato wedges
oh yeah fries whatever
no not bad chicken strippers oh
stripping it up
I'm just okay I mean
Pizza is usually amazing so I don't know
why you get chicken strips or fries at a
pizza place
oh the nachos no
oh no okay what have you done
you want to be a millionaire open a
decent Mexican restaurant in London
you're gonna try very hard just above
above horrible two or three steps the
line will be out the door oh my God my
soul hurts that's so terrible there went
to some exclusive U.S side options we
can't find in the UK firstly we have
tater tots now if I'm correct these are
basically balls of like mashed potato
which are then fried they can then be
topped with a range of things the ones
we've got here are Philly cheesesteak
tots
not bad they could be like slightly more
flavor going on then we have two stuffed
cheesy bread options as the name
suggests these are Big pieces of bread
topped with lots of cheese and a filling
of your choice here we have a spinach
and feta cheesy bread and then I believe
this one is bacon jalapeno cheesy bread
then we have two Twist options here we
have some garlic bread twists and
Parmesan bread twists now you don't eat
the Twist on their own because they come
with dips so this is a Cheesy marinara
dip
it's basically just a bowl of their
marinara sauce with lots of melted
cheese on top I kind of see the appeal
of Dipping these in marinara sauce I
don't know if it needs the cheese that's
such Overkill
I would enjoy that way more if it was
just marinara sauce in addition to the
cheesy marinara sauce option
there's also a five cheese dip that's
just pure oil
vegan nuggets
like this
Twisted dough balls I bet that was
better when it was hot again why are you
getting this instead of pizza
because it's the elements of pizza these
are the chicken kickers compared for
that kick
and I don't think it's coming to be
honest this slaw looks a little rough
but you get a real big tub of coleslaw
we're still talking about sides but now
we're on to chicken dominoes in the US
has some Wing options which we can't
find in the UK we'll start with these
ones here which are garlic parmesan
wings they have not skimped on the
garlic Palm sauce although I will say
these are tiny wings
oh chicken is this color this is the
world's smallest chicken
maybe one of the worst Wings I've ever
had
the sauce is like a weird gloopy texture
which I really do not appreciate doesn't
even taste nice and the other Wing
option we got today was sweet mango
habanero I'll give these a quick try the
bar is pretty low after those garlic
Palm wings I have to say it's definitely
better than the other one the sauce
actually tastes kind of nice A little
bit of tweaking the method I think would
go a long way dominoes so please fix
this because these are not very good
Domino's in the US also has boneless
wings
I'm still not exactly sure what counts
as a boneless wing versus a nugget but
they're calling these boneless wings
we've got two options today which are
the crispy bacon and buffalo chicken
I'll have a quick bite of the crispy
bacon
these have been disappointing I thought
Americans did Wings better than this I'm
going to be honest there are two other
bonus Wings which are a sweet barbecue
bacon and a spicy jalapeno but we didn't
get those today Domino's in the US also
offers a range of sandwiches and pastas
I don't know why because they all look
real bad I'll work my way down this way
starting with the Italian sandwich a
chicken palm and once again a Philly
cheesesteak although I feel like if you
tried to sell this in Philly they would
run you out of town there were some
other sandwiches we didn't get today
including a buffalo chicken a chicken
habanero a Mediterranean veggie and a
chicken bacon ranch then we're on to the
pasta options the ones I have in front
of me today are a chicken alfredo and a
pasta primavera I'm going to be honest
after trying all the pizzas I am not
going to try these for the sake of my
health I've heard from Joe that they are
all terrible
I think the pastas had dominoes are an
absolute Abomination and looking at them
I believe them all right it's time for
sauce talk foreign exchange
sauce talk
[Music]
thank you garlic and herb dip
this isn't Ranch but it's pretty close
oh you have a vegan one I can taste the
difference but this one's pretty good
too honey and mustard
I think honey mustard good well it's
actually really good like your sauces
are good Tangy salsa okay I think this
is where we're about to fall off a cliff
here so no there's no way you got salsa
right you know what it is it's like
there's tomato sauce here's salsa you're
like
just stopped like here oh Duff ranks
USA Baby all the way from Jersey
um
yep that's Frank's I know why I did that
there are four Source options in the US
which we don't have in the UK and these
are a marinara sauce a blue cheese sauce
ranch dressing and a sweet mango
habanero I will very quickly give these
all a try
it's fine the marinara sauce
is very sweet blue cheese dressing
I like a little bit of blue cheese on
wings it can be very overpowering
[Music]
oh no no it's not even that it's like
too much blue cheese it's just like
there's some kind of odd flavor in that
just tastes like slightly soured of
course we have the ranch they put this
on some of their pizzas directly
and for the real Ranch lovers you can
then also dip your crusts in it as well
I can't open this because my hands are
covered in Grease
it's quite Tangy and last but not least
the sweet mango habanero I quite like
this on the wings
I think this is like by far the best and
like most well balanced of any of these
sauces uh looks like for desserts you
guys got cookies
last one oh god what the hell is this
what do I even do with it
did I cut it did I just bite right into
it
listen to me
and what I can tell it's just pizza
dough with melted chocolate on it no
effort on this yeah that's weird then
the US has some dessert options which we
can't find in the UK over here we have
chocolate lava cake
okay no there is yeah there is some some
lava in there but still very gooey on
the inside
next up we have some cinnamon bread
twists so I think it's basically just
the same dough that they use for the
garlic or Parmesan bread twists but
instead of topping them with Savory
things they top them with cinnamon and
then give you some sweet icing for
dipping
this is really good
we don't have a lot of like cinnamon
roll Cinnabon type of stuff in the UK
which I think is a travesty because I
think it's really tasty
and honestly yeah these are pretty good
and then last but by no means least
we have the marbled cookie brownie I
feel like Domino's are like surprisingly
good at desserts that's really not bad
I think overall I have to say I'm kind
of disappointed by the US Dominoes menu
I was expecting some good flavors some
good textures and various bits and Bobs
but I really didn't get much of that
honestly my main takeaway is that I
didn't like most of the menu this may be
controversial considering how much I
hate vegetables but of all the Stan like
the pizza pizzas
already like predetermined ones I was
actually very impressed with the The
Volcano veggie or veggie volcano that's
like really good that was earlier was a
little more optimistic to be honest but
I was surprised by how much I liked this
so yeah that was a good one this sounds
kind of ridiculous to say but I think if
I had to take one menu item from the US
and bring it back with me to the UK I'd
probably take the cinnamon bread twists
probably the one that almost made me
throw up that'd be the tuna
horrifying
like I'm glad I know
but that was I mean it almost made me
throw up of the things on the U.S menu I
think the one that I would delete
permanently if I could would actually be
the Extravaganza I kind of said it at
the time but I think it's just far too
many toppings I think Joe agrees with me
on this one so I hope he doesn't push
back too hard but I think the more
toppings you add the kind of worse you
end up making a pizza there was not a
square centimeter of cheese on that
pizza it was just toppings toppings
toppings flavors were all over the place
it didn't know what pizza it was trying
to be it was just a disaster far too
much dialect back guys calm down yeah
the tuna Pizza is the worst thing I've
ever eaten that was so bad
that was made that way on purpose